I THINK WE CAN ONLY SAY, ARE
PEOPLE LITERALLY DEALING WITH
THEM RIGHT NOW IN TERMS OF
DEALING WITH THE MEETING.
>> Bret: PRESIDENT TRUMP
PRETTY PASSIVE ON THAT MEETING
WITH KIM JONG UN, SEEMING TO
HOPE TO GET IT BACK ON TRACK.
AT THE NORTH KOREAN SENT OUT A
SHOT, IF YOU WILL COME ABOUT
MILITARY EXERCISES WITH
SOUTH KOREA.
PRESIDENT TRUMP MET WITH THE
VICE PREMIER OF CHINA TODAY,
TWEETING OUT A PICTURE AND
SAYING THAT MEETING WENT WELL AS
CHINA PLAYS A SIGNIFICANT ROLE
OBVIOUSLY IN ALL OF THIS.
PLUS, THE CHINA TRADE
NEGOTIATIONS THAT ARE STILL
CONTINUING.
WITH THAT, LET'S BRING IN OUR
PANEL.
JONATHAN SWAN, NATIONAL
POLITICAL REPORTER FOR AXIOS.
THE ASSOCIATE EDITOR AT REAL
CLEAR POLITICS, AND ELI LAKE,
COLUMNIST FOR A BLOOMBERG VIEW.
JONATHAN, WHAT ARE THE INNER
WORKINGS OF THE WHITE HOUSE
THINKING ABOUT THE POSSIBILITIES
OF THE SUMMIT ON JUNE 12TH?
I HEARD KELLYANNE CONWAY SAYING,
IT COULD BE DELAYED.
>> I THINK IT'S ALWAYS BEEN AN
UNEASINESS, ALMOST EVERYTHING
WAS GOING TO WELL FOR A WHILE.
KIM JONG UN WAS RELEASING THE
HOSTAGES AND THEATRICALLY
DESTROYING THE NUCLEAR FACILITY.
BUT THE NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR HAS ALWAYS BEEN
SKEPTICAL ABOUT EVEN THE NOTION
OF TRUMP GOING OVER THERE AND
MEETING WITH HIM.
HE HAS BEEN THROUGH THIS
CAROUSEL BEFORE, AND HE DOES NOT
TRUST THE NORTH KOREANS.
HE'S NEVER HAD FAITH IN THE IDEA
THAT YOU CAN TAKE THEM AT THEIR
WORD.
I THINK HE HAD A VERY TOUGH
HARD-LINE THERE WITH JOHN FULTON
WHO IS TALKING TO THE PRESIDENT
EVERY DAY, AND THAT BEING SAID,
WE ARE BEING TOLD THAT THE
PRESIDENT WANTS TO DO THIS, ONCE
THE MEETING FACE-TO-FACE AND
THEY ARE CARRYING ON AS IF
NOTHING HAS CHANGED.
>> Bret: SPEAKING OF BOLTON,
HE WAS MENTIONED BY THE
NORTH KOREANS AND THE STATEMENT
SPECIFICALLY.
HE ALSO TOLD CHRIS WALLACE
SOMETHING THAT RAISED EYEBROWS
AND GOT SOME RESPONSE.
>> WE HAVE VERY MUCH IN MIND THE
LIBYA MODEL FROM 2003-2004.
THERE ARE OBVIOUSLY DIFFERENCES
IN THE LIBYAN PROGRAM WAS MUCH
SMALLER, BUT THAT WAS BASICALLY
THE AGREEMENT THAT WE NEED TO.
WE WILL WANT TO TEST NORTH KOREA
IN THIS FIRST MEETING FOR
EVIDENCE THAT THEY HAVE MADE
THAT STRATEGIC DECISION.
>> President Trump: THE LIBYAN
MODEL ISN'T THE MODEL THAT WE
HAVE AT ALL.
IN LIBYA, WE DECIMATED THAT
COUNTRY.
>> THE LIBYAN MODEL THAT BOLTON
IS TALKING ABOUT IS HOW THEY GOT
RID OF THEIR WEAPONS AND THEIR
ABILITY TO START ON THAT PROGRAM
ABILITY TO START ON THAT PROGRA
PROGRAM.
NOT THE ACTUAL END OF
MUAMMAR QADDAFI, AND HOW IT CAME
TO AN END.
>> WHILE THAT IS HOW THEY SEE IT
AND THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE
CONCERNED WITH AND THAT'S WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP REFERRED TO
TODAY.
AND FROM SOMEONE AT THE HESS
LEVELS OF THE GOVERNMENT, IT HAS
HAPPENED BEFORE.
HE ACTUALLY OFFERED THE
NORTH KOREAN LEADER SOME
PROTECTIONS TODAY, IF HE AGREES
TO DENUCLEARIZE.
I DO THINK THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION, AND PARTICULARLY
THE PRESIDENT IS HANDLING THIS
IN A VERY SHREWD WAY, WHATEVER
IT IS, WHETHER IT IS SABER
RATTLING OR WHATEVER, THAT
KIM JONG UN LOON IS DOING BY
CANCELING TALKS WITH THE
SOUTH KOREANS AND THREATENING AL
THE TENSION, THE PRESIDENT SAID
I'M TRYING TO GIVE EVERYONE THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT.
THEY ARE STILL TRYING TO AVERT
WAR AND STILL TRYING TO CREATE
DISCUSSION.
I BET EVERYTHING JONATHAN IS
SAYING IS TRUE ABOUT BOLTON'S
INFLUENCE AND TEMPERING THE
PRESIDENT'S EXPECTATIONS, BUT I
THINK THEY ARE HANDLING THE WAY
IT NEEDS TO BE HANDLED.
KIM JONG UN TOOK THOSE HOSTAGES,
TO RELEASE THEM.
SO FAR HE HAS BEEN WAY TOO
ACQUIESCENT IN HIS LANGUAGE, FOR
A LONG-STANDING GOAL OF THAT
REGIME TO BE BELIEVABLE.
AS THE PRESIDENT SAYS, WE WILL
SEE.
BUT THEY JUST NEED TO TRY TO GET
THE PROSPECT OF THIS ALIVE WELL
BEING CAUTIOUS.
>> Bret: ELI?
>> I WOULD SAY THAT I'VE BEEN
CONCERNED ABOUT THE NORTH KOREA
OUTREACH FOR SOME TIME, BUT IN
THE CONTEXT OF THE CHINA PART OF
THIS WHERE IT SEEMS THAT TRUMP
IS REVERSING HIMSELF ON THE ZTE
SANCTIONS, AND THIS IS AFTER A
LONG AND RIGOROUS LEGAL PROCESS.
I JUST THINK THAT ALL OF THIS IS
SENDING THE WRONG SIGNAL AT THIS
POINT.
THE UNITED STATES THAT CERTAIN
NORMS, PARTICULARLY WHEN IT
COMES TO ISSUES OF NUCLEAR
PLEURA FEDERATION
PROLIFERATION AND THINGS LIKE
THAT.
WHEN THE NORTH KOREANS TALK
ABOUT DENUCLEARIZATION, WHAT
THEY MEAN IS BREAKING THE
U.S.-SOUTH KOREA ALLIANCE.
SO IF WE DON'T HAVE
CLARIFICATION AT THIS POINT ON
IT, I DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
OPTIMISM FOR THESE TALKS.
AS MUCH AS I THINK IT'S
ADMIRABLE THAT THE PRESIDENT IS
AT LEAST TRYING, AND HE COULD
USE SOMEONE LIKE JOHN BOLTON,
HIS NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR,
AS A BIT OF LEVERAGE AND PERHAPS
INTIMIDATE A TYRANT LIKE
KIM JONG UN.
BUT THIS COULD BE VERY
TROUBLING.
OF COURSE THE LIBYA MODEL IS
WHAT WE ARE SEEKING AND WE WANT
TO GET RID OF THEIR NUCLEAR
PROGRAM.
WHAT ELSE ARE THEY SUPPOSED TO
BE TALKING ABOUT?
>> Bret: YES.
LET'S DO SUMMIT CASINO.
AS IT'S MOVING FORWARD, AND
WHERE ARE YOUR CHIPS ON THE
ROAD, JONATHAN?
>> PROBABLY 60.
>> I THINK 75.
I THINK THE DATE COULD CHANGE
BUT I THINK IT WILL HAPPEN
BECAUSE KIM JONG UN WANT THAT TO
HAPPEN.
>> I DIDN'T THINK WE WOULD GET
THIS FAR, BUT I'M WORRIED.
IF THEY CAN'T EVEN READ THAT THE